so let's start off with this first one
it's a video report
school infections are very high in
england at the moment are you sure it's
the right decision to not make masks
mandatory in schools and are you looking
at any additional measures to protect
children
so that's a bead and he's saying should
we not enforce mask wearing in schools
and any further protection
so a really good question from abby
if you remember when omikron
hit us we went to plan b and plan b
included masks and communal areas in
schools um i went further because i
looked at the evidence from uk um health
security agency and of course some of
the work we did in the department we did
an observational study of schools had
which had used masks in the classroom so
further than just in communal parts and
we did that um to make sure that the
reopening of schools um in january went
as smoothly as we could make it
and of course we had schools order test
kits that uh secondary school children
can be tested in that first week we had
something like 28 million test kits go
out um another 17 million by end of
january
now all of that has meant that 99.9 of
schools are open
um we're seeing um actually attendance
begin to tick upwards so we're at 89
percent attendance 99.9 as i say are
open
i think
the balance because we know that masks
in the classroom
does inhibit learning but much harder
to communicate much more difficult for
children to learn and i think now we're
at a stage where we're probably going to
be one of the first
major economies in the world to
transition this virus from pandemic to
endemic i think it's right that
we removed masks in the classroom as
soon as we could
and as the prime minister said yesterday
the dispatch box that on the 21st
of february when we're back after half
term he will set out the plan of how
we're going to live with covert and if
the data continues to move in the right
direction because we are data driven
then we will remove all restrictions a
month early we will come back to that um
but we've got so many questions to go
through this is from joanne taylor
i live in extra care
care managers here have been and are
really struggling to recruit carers and
catering staff bending over backwards
the vulnerable being held back
repeatedly from learning so in leveling
up for inequality why not extend the
vital help being deployed to hospitals
currently by our armed forces to within
our care sector also
great question
really great question and i know that
the health secretary
has been
paying a lot of attention to the case if
he's put hundreds of millions
more funding to make sure that the care
sector can um
get over the sort of the the
challenge of uh omicron and of course
people being off sick and that staffing
challenge
that's happening and i know that he will
do everything in his power to make sure
that that support continues to be in
place for the care sector it's an
important sector you remember during the
vaccination program you showed my clip
as the vaccine minister we focus very
much um in the first phase of the
vaccination program on getting into care
homes and getting those most vulnerable
protected as quickly as possible but i
know the health sector is looking to
make sure whatever he can do to to
mitigate against the the staff shortages
he's doing but um reducing you were
talking about the self-isolation and the
fact that it could end a month early i
mean what is that actually based on is
it is it going to be based on the
science there's a yuga poll that says
that 75 of britain's want the rules that
are in place at the moment to remain as
such 48 from them forever
well
as i said we're going to be
led by the data so if the data continues
to move in the right direction so if i
look at my own
uh department um we look at attendance
data and absenteeism
data
then we are in a better place this week
than we were
but what about the number of people that
are actually um contracting it
so again of course
we'll be led by the data at the moment
um as i did when i got omicron i
self-isolated immediately and then
waited until um i tested negative twice
and then
before i could actually come out of uh
isolation i couldn't come out on day
five or six because i was still testing
positive i had it quite severely um in
many ways the important thing is is that
we follow the data and what the premise
is saying is on the 21st he will come to
parliament set out the plan for living
with covert and if the data continues to
move in the directions moving in at the
moment
then we will be able to um by the 24th
a month early be able to to um
effectively ask you about that given
that that you brought up your covered
and you had it quite severely if you i
mean i know you're fully jabbed um and
you've had it before i'm guessing so no
it's my first time okay so how can you
contract it if you've had all these
three vaccines how do you convince
people that it's a good idea to have the
vaccinations well i can all i can say to
your viewers is i think without the
vaccine and the booster i'd have had it
even worse my doctor said uh because
it's your physiology and as he reminded
me and i knew this when i was vaccinated
minister that it's your your body's
reaction to covet that
will determine how severe or
asymptomatic you might be i've had you
know family members who had no symptoms
whatsoever
in my case it got worse it got into my
chest and had to sort of uh
increase the the sort of level of
medical help i needed um but he said
by day four five it got into my chest
and started
really
affecting my breathing and he found it
difficult to breathe heavier medication
and then he said one more day and i
might have to put you on two steroids or
something else that's heavier but it
luckily started to then recover that my
temperature went up to nine thirty nine
point five oh yeah no it wasn't was not
pleasant but
he reminded me and he said you know
whenever you go on
case program
that if you hadn't had the vaccines and
the booster he said i guarantee you you
had been in hospital and probably
intubated
that's not a good sign is that because
if you're going to get your vaccine and
get your booster it's never too late
the the offer is evergreen from the nhs
if you haven't had a vaccination go and
get your vaccine i promise you this
thing is not like a cold it's not going
to like a mild flu if it hits you
severely
and you're one of the unlucky ones it is
horrific it's not good you think you
could have died if you hadn't had the
vaccines i i certainly if i hadn't had
the vaccine i would have been in
in
big trouble um according to my doctor
okay thankfully you did and you're here
let's move on to school ventilation
should we this is from nicola cackett
she says all my nieces classroom windows
have to remain open to ventilate the
room but there's only one small radiator
in the room my niece is wearing thermal
leggings under several layers of clothes
and keeping her coat on in class and is
still cold all day
would your cabinet sit under these
conditions
nichola so what we did is we sent out
350 000 co2 monitors to make sure that
pretty much all the classrooms in our
schools are monitored we then got the
data back and did our own
modeling
that suggested that probably around 9000
air filtration units uh air purifiers
will be needed so we ordered those and
those are going out to the schools that
can't uh easily uh ventilate but
actually if you look at what we did with
schools
the vast majority were able to
cope and
effectively ventilate classrooms
relatively easily
but those that couldn't i made sure we
had the air purifiers by opening the
windows but i mean we're looking at
times educational supplement magazine
talking about one particular school uh
50 000 pounds for one month electricity
use and 13 000 pounds for gas um 54 000
pounds higher than the amount it
normally would have to fork out
absolutely one part of the
thing that i'm doing at the moment is
making sure we
in the department um keep our eye on
uh the cost of energy in the education
estate now the good news is the new
schools we're building we're building
500 new schools they're all at net zero
operation they are really unbelievably
energy efficient but that's yeah we
still have 24 300 plus school so uh it
puts it in in perspective where we're
trying to sort of mitigate um for those
schools that we can um but we're keeping
an eye as well on the energy uh costs
and the pressure we had a good
settlement during the spending review in
terms of uh school budget so for
secondary schools we're at uh 6150
pounds per pupil and for primary we're
at 4800 pounds more than they normally
pay is that something you look at we are
looking and making sure we're monitoring
the the cost of energy in in schools and
the impact
on schools so the one thing we did on uh
part of the covert um mitigations
is a fund back to the question around um
social care similar for schools for
if they needed temporary staff to help
with um staff shortages we put a fund
together but
we made sure that sr as well we actually
got
a good funding settlement because we we
knew
that actually the cost of things like
energy was going to to go up okay i have
to move on this literally several
questions we this is holly stafford um
holly has written this question for you
secretary of state where's the catch-up
tutoring we were promised my daughter is
in her gcse year and has received
nothing
holly
get in contact with
your school
every school has the opportunity to
take up the tutoring program
um we are
first term this year have done as many
tutoring hours as the whole of last year
we are committed to doing six million
tutoring
programs of 15-hour uh courses for
children of its target at the moment
well
no because actually if you there are
three pillars and
whether it's the times education
supplement or somewhere else that that
mentioned that they only looked at one
of the pillars so we've got you know
three pillars one is school led tutoring
which is the most successful because
schools told us actually why don't you
just give us the money and we will you
know hire in a tutor that we think is is
the right
uh individual uh to help children
recover um from
the the covert catch up kevin collins i
mean lots of people well just you don't
know how obviously former education
catch-ups are uh he quit uh last june
saying that the plans for pupils were
feeble
well
one
my very strong view is you
invest and then you evidence uh what you
do so we're making a five billion pound
investment in recovery now what i did
was i looked at the evidence the
evidence is that those as with the
question just now
with the least time left in education so
16 to 19 year olds need the most
effort so i went to the chancellor and i
said look i need 800 million for
recovery for the 16 to 19 year olds he
gave me that and then i wanted more
money for secondary primary for
disadvantaged children again because
it's important that we focus on
disadvantaged children to make sure they
recover as well and he gave me that
which is why we managed to get the total
to five billion now
tutoring is a really important part of
that
we'll do six million tutoring uh blocks
of 15 hours each 100 million hours in
total every school uh is eligible to
come forward and have
uh you know a part of that funding for
the national tutoring program i want
them to come forward i'm parents and i'm
writing to parents to say look you know
contact your school and find out if they
are taking advantage of the national
tutoring program
and then make sure that actually i
monitor
have we caught up have we recovered if
we haven't i'll go back to treasury and
ask for more money
because what i want to do is by the end
of this parliament is make sure that
every child has had the opportunity to
recover okay
perhaps one of the ways to do that is
more homework or not raquel dealey has
written to us this morning morning
raquel if you're watching my son is 11
and currently
completes anywhere from two to three
hours of homework every night what is
the education secretary's view on how
much homework is acceptable for each
student in a secondary school what
happens in your house uh mia does a lot
of work um that's your little girl
that's she's nine um
the boys are now grown up and graduated
um but
i mean two to three hours is too much
two to three hours is a lot of homework
i think in many ways i suspect raquel um
that the school is
rightly focused on recovery and catch-up
and i was at hammersmith academy
a few weeks ago to see the brilliant
work that the leadership team gary
kinnison is a brilliant head teacher you
should have him on this program okay we
will um but um they were saying to me
look the way we're dealing with recovery
is to see where the gaps are and then
really focus on those for those kids so
the best thing that rachel can do is
talk to the uh her
her son or daughter's teacher uh to
acknowledge that it's too much just
three hours i i think it's look we've
got to trust our teachers and our head
teachers they know best if i sit on your
program
and pronounce on racquel's you know
child's uh homework
you will think that everybody in the
profession will think i'm you know the
one he says is the evidence-led
secretary of state yet he's arrogantly
pronouncing on this stuff the reality is
the teachers know best what each child
needs to recover and i think they're
doing a great job in delivering okay
raquel i don't think you need to do two
he doesn't need to do two three hours of
homework and i i had a little boy and i
would not have had him doing that no
matter what the education secretary is
saying this morning i think he's half
agreeing with you anyway uh what about
this from helen this is helen uh why
have private schools been using teacher
assessments under covid as an excuse to
boost their grades the sunday times
reports that in one case their a star
rate went from 33 percent
to 90 last summer i saw that uh report
and in fact um
this week
uh i had the regulatory off call and i
discussed this with them and they
reassured me a couple of things and i
want to just reassure the viewers on
this
one is that
every allegation
is investigated by the exam boards and
all the records have been kept so none
of the records of the teacher
assessments um have been
destroyed or gone away so if there are
any new allegations they will
investigate them as well they also
reassured me that that actually when you
look at whether it's independent schools
or academies uh the children who were
expected to get um high grades a grades
actually
achieved those every head teacher had to
sign you know really really stringent um
letter of verification that they
followed the assessment correct
a star grade at a level reached 39.5 in
2021 compared to 16
in 2019.
something going on there well and and we
we saw which is why
i want to go back to exams and which is
why i'm determined to go back to exams
for gcses as a levels this summer um
look there is no perfect system all i
can say is from all the evidence the
best system we have is having going back
to examinations we're doing that
sensitively we're doing it in a way that
recognizes that children's education has
been disrupted um at the beginning of
the week
off call actually put out through uh the
exam boards further information as to
what the the content of the exams will
be to help those uh children preparing
for their exams i think that's the right
thing we're not leaping back to
pre-covered um grading because i think
that would also be unfair we're doing it
in two steps so going halfway and then
this summer and then going back to
pre-covert next year that's also i think
important so these mitigations i think
recognize the disruption but i think
examination is the best way
of making sure we deliver rigor
it's also saying that you know if you
leave it to her teachers and and
teachers more generally then they're
easing up those grades well look
as i say we we saw
some of that great inflation come
through because it was
um you know teacher assessed we're going
back to examination i think that's the
right thing to do the um information
landed really positively on monday and i
think the feedback from the sector from
across you know from the front line has
been really positive and students want
to go back they make their preparations
they want to go back and and and have
take the exam whether it's gcses or a
levels okay well coming up to um 20 past
nine we're ripping through those but
still so many um to go this one
obviously that is talking about state
education this is from david west david
good morning to you david wants to know
uh a year's fee to attend eaton is 44
000 pounds
how does that institution deserve
charity status that exempts it from a
whole range of taxes
so
the independent sector
50 of them have charitable uh status
including um including eaton um i want
to see
uh those schools do much more um uh to
open up to
children from disadvantaged backgrounds
they're doing a lot already they want to
do more with us on
our journey which is the really my focus
uh which is a system that is diverse so
we have
academies we have free schools we have
independent sector that's a good thing i
think in an education
system they want to do more on that
journey uh where we get uh every child
to have a great education in every part
of the country at the right time in the
right place um
but i think it's also important uh that
they play their part
in what does that look like
well
you know can we
get
our independent schools to join us on
what the evidence suggests is the best
way forward which is a family of schools
that are well managed you know tightly
managed really well supported
in a multi-academy trust that's
high-performing that we know the
evidence delivers the best outcome for
every child i always tell my story when
i arrived on these shows at the age of
11. i couldn't speak a word of english
but i had parents who valued education
my mother was a dentist in iraq and they
pushed me hard i want the system to
deliver for the child whose parents
don't have that wherewithal everywhere
you know whether you're in blackpool or
london or manchester or birmingham that
every school delivers a great quality
education and i've got the evidence of
how we can do it i want every part of
the education sector to join me on that
journey including our independent
schools but if we tax those independent
private schools then there's 1.7 billion
pounds available according to labour for
state schools so i saw that and i also
saw some of the analysis done on this
that actually if you do
do that you will
not increase the tax take for the
exchequer actually go the other way
because many uh uh
parents will will come out of the
independent sector and actually will
will add
to the number of of children that we
would need to accommodate in the state
sector and i think that would be wrong i
follow the evidence i will always be the
evidence-led secretary of state as i did
with with vaccines working you know
cross-party with
sadiq khan who i know you've had on your
program and andy burnham and andy street
and birmingham i will always follow the
evidence is not there on this having a
diverse ecosystem of education with you
know the the the
academy program being
clearly evidence you know the the best
way of organizing a family of schools if
they're really well supported not every
academy by the way
does well there are some schools and
academies that coast i'm going to deal
with that especially through the
leveling up white paper with michael
gove in those educational investment
areas we announced uh but a lot of work
to do but i think we've got the evidence
to deliver a system that delivers for
every child okay you touched on this but
uh etrus um has said been good enough to
send us a question so i perhaps you
could reiterate your thoughts on this
why are the 2022 exams still going ahead
we've missed a year of learning due to
covert many topics haven't been taught
with further disruptions that only
months towards the actual exams gcses
are setting my year up for failure let
teachers graders they know what they're
capable of i trust
i think that the best way
to assess
a student's work is through examination
there's no perfect way but what i've
tried to do
is be sensitive to the fact that your
education has been disrupted which is
why uh we on monday um through the exam
boards made more information available
as to what
you will be examined on whether you're
doing a gcse as or an a level uh so the
subject matter is much clearer for your
teachers so they can focus on those uh
parts of the subject that will be in the
examination
we are being more generous with the
grading we're not going back to
pre-covert grading this year we're going
halfway and then we'll we'll go to
pre-covert the year after
i think all those mitigations are the
right things because they recognize that
disruption that you've been through
i thank every student for the resilience
they've shown we've just done our survey
state of the nation survey of students
and they've seen unbelievable resilience
um including some real pressure on
well-being and mental health as well as
of course um you know recovery uh in
their education but real resilience and
i thank you for that but examination is
the best way and the fairest way forward
okay with that in mind uh mark gower has
sent us uh this video last question for
the education secretary why does the
government have to increase national
insurance contributions for the nhs when
the nhs was promised
315 million a week after leaving the eu
uh oh
because we actually made that 350
million available
um after we left the u for the nhs the
nhs funding uh
is is increasing to 36 billion
um uh uh by 36 people i should say
because we recognize there's a backlog
that is currently at six million could
be as high as uh 11 or 13 million before
we begin to bring it down plus
so going up for two years yes and
actually more
equally importantly i should say that
adult social care which i know you know
i've been in politics a very long time
that successive governments uh have
attempted to grapple with it have then
failed and this government under boris
johnson has actually dealt with it and
that national insurance rights yes as
you look at these figures i mean it's
staggering i'll share them with with the
viewers i'm sure you know already the
nhs accounts for 40
of day-to-day government spending under
labour it was 28
how can we say that the nhs is value for
money well because the nhs had to deal
with a global pandemic um and
that has
in enormous consequences whether it is
what we did with vaccines um which
actually now is making us one of the
most dynamic economies
in the world will probably be one of the
first major economies in the world to
transition this virus from pandemic to
enemy thanks to the nhs but the nhs also
um
yeah with
the the the the focus of the prime
minister has
come up with a
adult social care strategy that will
finally work and not break people in old
age uh where we know this this is you
know pretty harrowing for families when
they have too many is that what you're
saying i think the nhs delivers great uh
work
they can always improve the if you ask
nhs leadership they're the first to say
that actually reform is good look at
what we did
again with vaccine the data we went to
you know from sort of fortnightly to
weekly to daily data real granularity by
postcode by
ethnicity by um you know
lots of different ways to cut and slice
the data so that we can see who is being
vaccinated where and where we need to
focus resources data and transparency is
our ally on this journey to get real
reform in the nhs and to deliver better
outcomes in any complex system right the
best way you can deal with it is if you
measure everything and publish it
because people are going to can see
and then the system will become more
human and improve we've got time for a
few more i hope so i hope so including
fred syriacs from first dates more from
him in just a second but first this is
jane talking about long covert
my daughter has been battling with long
covid since march 2020
she's only in school six hours a week on
the doctor's orders and has had to drop
to just two gcses because her body can't
cope with the exam process
what will the government do to support
these children within a discriminatory
system
apparently something like 120 000 kids
in that position
and and one of the things that we did
actually i met
some students through first news um when
they came to see me in the department
and that's the newspaper for the
absolute and which has a collaboration
with sky news um
and um
who was she was telling me about her
struggle with long cove which is why
um
under matt hancock when i was back in
the health department uh we put you know
serious amounts of funding into um the
research into long covered and
helping gps understand and identify uh
long covert because actually much of
this is about diagnosis and then that
would then allow the whole system the
the the education system and the
healthcare system to work together to be
able to help those children okay um we
talked we certainly touched on special
education needs earlier on i do want to
hear what jack has to say
ask someone with an awesome diagnosis i
wasn't given the support i needed at
school i was quite misunderstood which
led to me being excluded which had an
impact on my education
so i'd like to ask the education
secretary what are the government's
plans to ensure that children who have a
learning difficulty or a developmental
disability are being provided with
adequate support in schools and that
their needs are met handsome young man
isn't he hi jack a very good morning if
you're watching do you feel that you're
letting people like jack down i think
we're gonna do more for jack so one of
the things that i'm doing is the um
send the special educational needs and
disabilities review and i'll be
publishing
basically i'm looking at the whole
system um to see how we can deliver
better outcomes for uh jack and for his
education and his family and his health
um so you know the the reforms that we
delivered when we first came to office
in the coalition government were good so
that children can have an uh education
health and care plan um but we need to
revisit those to i think make sure that
they're working everywhere and they're
working consistently now that's my sort
of review the green paper as uh we call
it in in
westminster jargon um but i didn't wait
for that i also went to the chancellor
at the spending review and i said look
we need more money because we need more
places more sufficiency in the system
now
and so he gave us 2.6 billion to invest
in more places for uh specialist places
as well as mainstream places because i
think you need both what would you say
to jack specifically when he feels that
he'd been let down i say sorry and i say
i will do better i promise you one of
the opportunities i have is the stars of
a line nicely i've got a school's white
paper which we will publish next month
which will
outline my vision for the education
system and how we deliver that great you
know education for every child at the
right place at the right time in every
part of the country but with it i've got
the children's social care review and
the scnd review and actually for the
first time in department education we
can actually knit all three together
because you need for for children with
special educational needs you need the
school system to be equally responsive
as the health care system
needs to be it's not just kids that are
struggling at school this is
from richard from bedfordshire hi
richard he um has written to us to say
my wife is a head teacher in a small
rural lower school performing the duties
of seven other people working until nine
or ten o'clock most nights on the verge
of some kind of breakdown what is the
school supposed to do when a class has
three pupils with specific requirements
and no support staffed due to sickness
richard i
through you richard i want to thank your
wife because that these are the sort of
stories
that uh you know make me feel that we've
got to burn out though
which is why we're putting so much
effort to make sure that you know you
saw in your clip when we started the
program of my
call for retirees to come forward for
this period when we're dealing with the
pandemic as we transition it omicron hit
us hard especially on on staffing uh and
actually what um richard's wife has done
is fantastic i've seen it is it gonna
get easier
it will be uh one obviously
because as we yeah transition this virus
as we see um infection rates begin to
drop
further we're seeing um
teacher absence also beginning to tick
down um we're at nine
percent absence in the system uh this
week which is a tick down a little bit
needs to come down further um then
things will get better and better and of
course supply teachers are an important
part of that which is why
you know my my big call before christmas
to say anyone who can volunteer come
forward um join the spy agencies uh did
and we actually did a call around about
10 supply agencies and found that around
500 people had actually come forward
from just the 10 of agencies which is
good which means there's at least a few
more thousand people who wouldn't have
come forward
who came forward still not enough i
still feel yeah
that's an inadequate answer for
richard's wife i just want to say thank
you from the bottom of my heart because
99.9
of schools are open because of people
like rich's wife and the support that
she gives those children do you ever
watch um first dates on channel four
yeah
yes well he's got a question for you
let's do it let's do it
we only have about 130 catering colleges
in total in the uk this is not enough to
produce the necessary manpower to
sustain hospitality let alone grow it
so what is the plan for professional
education
thanks fred
great question and one of the first
visits i made was westminster kingsville
who have a brilliant catering uh program
uh
in their college really fantastic but we
need more
and um we don't have enough waiting
stuff
people don't see it as a job as a career
they just see it as something to do as a
transition and fred's saying that's not
good enough absolutely right which is
why my big focus and we are in national
apprenticeship week this week
is to make sure that we continue to
invest in apprenticeships we're going to
raise rich is giving us 2.7 billion by
2024
to invest in
apprenticeships that's good we want to
see more of those in hospitality
industry and i want to see some we now
have some of the best brands of
restaurants and hotels in the united
kingdom they all need more staff high
quality training is so important to this
what are you doing and so i want them to
come forward we will do everything in
our power in the department to
facilitate
making this happen we're just doing a
similar thing in the creative industry
with the bbc actually tim davey came to
see me it was going so well until you
said that i'm sorry i am sorry but
they've done it well
they're great because actually in many
ways creative industries has lots of
long tail of small businesses who might
not themselves want an apprenticeship
you know full-time and so having having
the ability to have that uh you know
part-time and sharing of of
apprenticeships is really important for
the creation so fred can reach out to
you and fred come and see me i will i
absolutely want to see him i've seen
other sort of major players in the
hospitality industry who want to do the
same uh in
in birmingham and in other parts of the
country where they want to you know
maybe build a a a new facility a bigger
facility okay for the catering industry
i'll put you two together then uh right
this is a text from everyone knows dave
i'm not sure i do but we'll go with it
dave
what number do you get when you subtract
the number of resignations in the past
few days from the number of parties
investigated by sue gray see where he's
going with that the answer is apparently
11. um but you know we saw the picture
in the daily mirror yesterday didn't we
with the prime minister with the
champagne at one of those parties um how
damaging is what's been going on at
danny street for you guys
so look i think there is no doubt that
uh you know the
stories around uh parties have cut
through and people
uh were rightly angry to see that those
who were making the rules
have allegations put against them that
they're not obeying the rules i think
the police are uh looking at all those
um uh allegations that sue grey has
given them i think they've got a reel
and a half hundreds of pages of uh
report and pictures to look at i think
it's only right dave that they should do
that and do their work properly and then
i'll happily submit myself to k burley
and come and and and explain and and
answer any questions necessary in terms
of our focus i can tell you skills
schools family is my focus we're
delivering we're we're in national
apprenticeship week this week we've had
mental health week
really really focused delivery in my
department similarly in
other departments across government
whether it's transport or
in department for energy on the the cost
of living uh christ and the spike in gas
prices globally that we've seen you know
the focus of this government is to
recover the economy from covert make
sure that we recover the nhs more
doctors more nurses more police officers
uh on our doorstep
and make sure that we uh deliver uh the
the the
the outcomes that people want to see for
their children
because the best way to level up the
most valuable resource on earth is the
human resource and if i can deliver the
great education for every child in our
country the opportunities i had to sit
before you as secretary of state for
education
um for every child and i would have done
something truly great that is my focus
dave i promise you that is what i spend
all of my time on okay be pleased to
know that these are not my questions
today so i will not be grilling you on
that but i will
in the fullness of time let me leave it
to david um craigs he says he describes
himself as a former conservative member
and he says as education secretary what
sort of example do you think the prime
minister's behaviour sets for young
people and what effect do you think your
continued support and close association
with him
um has on your reputation
so david i take the view that you treat
everybody with respect you
share the evidence with them you explain
what you're trying to achieve
and i think most people will then
you know
i hope join in the endeavor and on that
journey that's what i'm seeing across
the board um whether i'm working
with
teachers and head teachers um our
universities or
our colleges
that is what i see i've always done that
the prime minister my
dealings with him has always dealt with
me respectfully and always engaged on
the evidence and has backed me when i
said to him you know
i don't know what i've told you this
story but
you know in the middle of the
vaccination program um
we had an offer from fisa biontic to say
we can offer you now but you have to
make a decision in a week
for vaccines that you may need if
there's a variant that you need to boost
against in the winter but you have to
tell us now
so months earlier
seven months or before the advice some
of the advice was we don't need it we're
absolutely fine because this thing won't
need a booster um i went to the pm and
said actually i think we really should
take this just in case and he took that
decision without that decision
1.6 billion a lot of money
wow a lot of money uh but but
nevertheless he took that without that
decision we would never have a booster
campaign i promise you that dave right
and so on the big calls
this prime minister has got them right
whether you know
delivering brexit i mean i remember the
pain of the last government where the
parliament was paralyzed we couldn't do
anything but we delivered brexit on the
first vaccination program to get the
first vaccine approved anywhere in the
world with fisa beyond take i remember
that the first 8th of december was the
date we delivered that first jab
in the uk then the booster campaign and
now
the omicron pre-christmas there were
lots of advice saying lock down lock
down lock down harder right he said no
i'm looking at the evidence we don't
need to because we will destroy
ourselves we'll destroy the economy harm
people's mental well-being if we lock
down on the big calls he got them right
well he's you know he came to parliament
apologized you know we've made a mistake
and he came back again um
after sue gray's publication and said
it's not good enough to just say we made
him say we've got to change and he's
making those changes now well we'll see
what happens when the police report back
just as far as astrazeneca is concerned
quite a lot of criticism for the
astrazeneca is it is it does it do what
it says on the tin yes it does it's a
great vaccine
and i tell you for why because if you uh
look at what we've been able to do in
the uk both remember vaccines
have
an impact both on
your antibody levels and t cells and
t-cells are sort of more
dormant in in your body and they sort of
awaken when the virus hits and they
really begin to help you fight the virus
and astrological has done brilliantly uh
for us here in the uk and i've had two
astrological vaccines followed by a
pfizer booster that's a really good uh
combination uh to have all fisa fires
are followed by fisa or madonna also a
good combination to have but astrazeneca
has been the workhorse of the world over
2.5 billion doses have protected people
around 2.5 billion at no profit
to astrazeneca the oxford team with the
backing of the government with boris
johnson another call from boris to say
we won't take a profit while the
pandemic is with the world
and astrologer agreed to that they're
bored back that and agreed to that
that's a really great thing and i'm
incredibly proud of that okay
this is from um gary i'm not sure how
you'll feel about this question uh gary
mccardle texting will your horses have
to choose between heating or eating as
the upcoming cost of living bites that's
in relation of course to the fact that
you claimed for um heating your stables
as part of your
expenses
and i'm sorry gary and and uh
i
apologized at the time as soon as i
discovered that um where could it have
happened well i tell you what happened
uh exactly so we i we brought up a small
holding a a cottage and
stables that my wife
looks after um and
there was a meter in the stables and
meet her at the house and
i thought that um the
heating claims that we were making were
uh for the meter reading in the house it
turned out that actually the two meters
were uh connected i ca as soon as i
found out i went to the parliamentary
um uh
investigator and said look this is what
happened i'm mortified they looked into
it they investigated thoroughly and they
found to be for it to be a genuine
mistake and i apologized and i uh paid
back uh the money and i i said again
gary
are you embarrassed
it's a it's a stupid thing to to have um
uh you know
not been able to to to spot but um it
was a genuine mistake and as soon as i
found out i i went to the
parliamentary uh to ipsa and and
explained look
here's the evidence here's here's what
happened i'm sorry that was then this is
now um and we were speaking to sadiq
khan um yesterday um
and this is what he said about you
nadeem sahabi is the best achieving
secretary in the last 11 years good
example of of a labour politician
uh saying good things about a tory
politician uh one of the things about
nadeem i met him two weeks ago is uh he
puts psych party politics and works for
the common good and he's also quite
interested in fun so good luck with that
that's nice that is nice it's really i
tell you what's been
truly remarkable and it's something that
i think we need to do more of
is in the vaccination program
i worked with sadiq in london and andy
burnham in manchester and andy street in
birmingham all the other
mayors around the country
i briefed them regularly we worked
together i shared the evidence with them
and they all stepped up when i was
children vaccines were the children and
minister under theresa may before
vaccines uh children and family minister
we did tremendous work with andy burnham
on
those in care and those who are leaving
care uh care leave the covenant he
really helped me lead on that uh andy
burnham it's that sort of collaboration
if you follow the evidence we're doing
the same now on skills so the local
skills improvement plans i'll be working
with
sadiq and
the other mayors to make sure that we
get the local skills improvement plans
around the country right that's a
bottom-up approach to what skills needs
uh are necessary in the economy and then
i've also launched the unit for future
skills
which is something that singapore's had
for many years we don't have that in the
uk where we'll be able to pull in data
from everywhere hmrc from student loan
book companies so we can see what the
skills needs of the economy are next two
years five years 10 years so that i can
then flex the infrastructure i spent 86
billion a year in education
i can flex all that infrastructure to
where the economy needs those skills
what does that do it gives those kids
the real opportunity for a great
education and a great job at the end of
it and the name's zahari nadim zahawi
and you're going to pinewood later or
not you know where they fulfilled you
see what i did there not quite double
07.
film james bond what's the plan
um so we're gonna get excited about
going i'm very excited about going uh
we're gonna look at their apprenticeship
program they've done a brilliant uh
apprenticeship program uh there so we're
gonna have a look i've signed an nda so
i can't talk about what they're gonna
show oh how exciting all i can say it's
it's a big blockbuster
um uh production that they've they've
got on that they're going to show me uh
oh i i get a behind the scenes fantastic
peak at the work they're doing but it's
been a phenomenal number 10 wasn't it
this was yeah with the bt apprentices uh
that was earlier this week they are
phenomenal
i tell you what great ambassadors for
the apprenticeship program any family
watching this program if your kids are
thinking about you know the future
whether it's you know they do a levels
and what they want to do think about a t
level we're going to make t levels as
famous that's right for tory leader now
not toury leader
it's it's t level so i'm going to make t
levels as famous as a levels t levels i
hear you ask are
a fusion between an apprenticeship and
an a level okay and you can either go to
university with them i think we've got
16 institutions now accepting
t levels or you can go and work and have
a great career with t levels so we're
doing microsoft t levels we're doing
lots of other t levels they are going to
be as famous as a levels if i do my job
right okay and unless i let you go i'm
going to be in a lot of trouble with
your team so i must let you go but 45
minutes of questions for out of
thousands that we received and answered
them honestly and openly and we very
much appreciate it thank you very much
indeed for joining us secretary state
thank you